it's time for true crime
[Music]
[Applause]
before the break we told you about fred
everett and his guard cat bandit and now
they're here i'm so excited i got so
into oh there you go oh
hi fred
hi bandit
hey drew
oh hi fred i this
my god and is like i am not having this
right now
whoa
okay
all right
she wore me out so fred i heard that you
typically stay up late watching old
movies is this true it's very true i'm a
retired surgeon and uh i don't have
schedules i have to keep unless i'm
traveling things like that so i stay up
late this particular night you didn't
stay up late is that correct
that's correct i was in bed by about
midnight
cats are notorious for
night feeders night prowlers stuff like
that
and and that's what happened that night
is
we have double sliding glass doors out
to
our deck
and it's perfect level for our stray cat
to come in on one side and my cat will
be on the other side separated by a thin
plain pant of glass
and they sit there and growl and it's
almost demonic i mean just a
low type thing and i heard that i got
halfway and then i went back not to
sleep but i was just kind of in that
stage and she comes racing into the
bedroom jumps on me pulls and scratches
on the comforter and actually got my
arms a couple times she was determined
to get me up and so i said okay you know
at that the worst i'm going to have to
shoe off a stray cat you know
uh flipped on the light the kitchen here
is two
younger individuals
lower 20s probably i'm not good on ages
but one had a pistol and one had a
crowbar
and um
obviously
robbery in progress um i ran back to uh
the master bedroom and picked up a
weapon
that i could defend myself with and by
the time i got back to the kitchen they
had fled on foot wow i i i totally
credit bandit for preventing that oh you
banned it
is it true that there's a sweet story of
how bandit came into your life
uh yeah i've always um
i've always done a lot of work with all
kind of charities um
one of them being uh the humane society
because i love animals and uh i was uh
going down i actually was gonna write a
check i did write a check uh at the
humane uh shelter
and i said you don't have any kittens
and they brought out three and one of
them was bandit oh
this this kid got in drawers pulled out
stuff i went wow what kind of energy is
that i love this that you saved bandit
and then bandit saved you yes it is
exactly
that's how it works with rescue animals
absolutely and we wanted to do something
to honor you and bandit so today our
friends at cats pride are donating ten
thousand dollars to the tupelo humane
society hi
how about that
wow
that's right
and my step my step granddaughter and
step-son just opened the first um cat
cafe in mississippi it's in tupelo and
it's called twisted whiskers oh yeah
they've already they've already placed
30 cats since they opened this summer so
kudos to them yeah absolutely
twisted whiskers and that's not all we
have something else um they have a
litter for good program where for every
jug of cat's pride litter sold they
donate a pound of litter to animal
shelters in need and they'd like to give
an additional five thousand dollars
worth of litter to the shelter as well
all right
and all of this is in honor of fred and
bandit thank you so much fred for
sharing your story and we thank bandit
and we are going to put your um
children's uh or your is it your son or
your daughter who opened a twisted
whiskers uh my grandstepchildren well
we're gonna we'd love to feature them on
our website and continue to support and
foster and just thank you thank you so
much for telling us your story we just
love you thank you and give bandit
kisses for us
you said thank you so much it's been
really really nice thank you thank you
oh the cutest
[Music]